[Laughter]
standout podcast
we're back again me and the boys boys
back in town we're deep off in the mains
this time as you can see different setup
and all that
looking all lovely back next to me got
right hand man
actually no right hand man's missing
today shout out to ozio we got
me he's out here here looking longer
than ever elbow the real north and are
back again
and we're joined by a special guest
special guest goods he's here today
man man like what extension rebellion
king he's here
is it extension
[Music]
shout out the bricklayers arms best pub
in shoreditch if you're looking for a
real pub experience real place to drink
real english
proper brothers charlotte they say where
you come charlotte street
in the sunny shoreditch hipster central
hipster capital come here
real people real pub real drinks
that's a great show still my life
let's go now let's go let's run this
let's go so as i said we talked about
coving and coronavirus
we're here with goods that's our guest
today who has some very strong opinions
on what is guanine right now in our
world
so first off my first question to you
is coronavirus real quick that's your
question that's my first question
is it in my opinion in your humble in my
humble opinion no
what the entire thing is the entire so
you're saying the entire illness
is fake so like yeah in it see yeah it's
a strong statement in it
manslaughter's mad but like if you look
at how you straight away the first thing
i'm going to say is you look at how you
how you identify a virus in it yeah
right as it's been done since 1984
you have to purify a virus and you have
to isolate it in popular culture
the truth to see that that thing as a
virus grows in it that hasn't ever been
done
okay what i'm saying yeah i'm not and
one thing it has to say in this
obviously man's not a doctor i'm not a
scientist right
i've never really been into science am i
going in science bro you know what i
mean
right i'm not i'm everything today's
opinions isn't it
i'm just
the fat checkers are owned by certain
companies because they've got a certain
thing
they've got a certain agenda yeah yeah
yeah that's that's
again that's funny enough ironic that's
fact you get me you can go and find out
yeah i mean but that's just my opinion
brother it's madden
think that are you exactly are you
naturally quite um
skeptical about the government 100
percent yeah
always has been yeah like if you know me
in it you would know that
i don't know how to put it in it i
wouldn't say man's a rebel wouldn't it i
just see things differently yeah yeah
i mean even if i'm if i'm stoned you
know what i'm saying so i'm acting a
certain way if mine stressed out like
you might know me from uni like i didn't
you know i mean that was the years
really like say us free
harry blah blah even sebi that's that's
how you know man in it but yeah i've
always been like quite skeptical you
know what i'm saying for me bro
there's loads of things that just don't
make sense and then that's why i started
reading into it started reading into the
science you know what i mean starting to
start to learn about students
starting to learn about medical studies
how um how long they take to really put
together say like a piece of information
um that you should give out you know
what i'm saying like say for example
there's no medical study
to say that most are proven to work to
block a virus
if you look at the size of particles of
the virus again scientifically they say
it's like putting a fence a metal fence
up for sheep to keep out mosquitoes
you know you know what i'm saying i like
that like that's that's again that's
that's probably that's a few scientists
a few scientists have come out and said
that
um i could like i said i've gone for
time i can't i know
anything is difficult for people because
there's scientists and people
with doctor in front of the name saying
that and the sciences of people
understand saying a complete opposition
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] bad difficult
it's very difficult like
100 bro like even i can't go and i can
but like convos with my mom
my dad like certain people almost
need to believe it because like my mom
she hasn't come out and said that you
know i mean like my mom
blah blah blah but for her work she
can't say certain things because of her
work you know i mean
even if she does have an opinion i'm not
saying she does or whatever
man i disagree with like my parents on
it you know what i mean like
but for me it's like again that's what
i'm saying on the insta team but it all
comes from love bro because it's not
like i'm trying to
be out here and be like i'm right yeah
oh
i'm gonna be right you guys are wrong
it's really interesting
you two here man says it out of love you
know yeah yeah this is what i truly
believe
you've been very vocal you're not
telling people you're like
you've got your information but here's
the other side still make your mind up
yeah
for me to feel how i feel in it yeah and
for people to almost accept that
i have to accept how you feel in it
that's only writing it that's like
treating how you should be treated in it
man sits here and gives my opinions like
you know good whatever you respect the
opinion a man who listens to it
i have to listen to yours yeah that's
just that's just respect between
friends or whatever you know what
everyone's saying it's a conversation
yeah and that's how it should be treated
yeah
i mean we are in a world now that people
aren't taking your opinions yeah but
again they don't
man's not doing it but all people are
getting absolutely destroyed for their
opinions
people are getting absolutely destroyed
people are getting their medical
licenses taken off them like
some my mom's on northern ireland she
was a gp for 30 years in it yeah
and she came out and said certain things
now she's getting basically getting her
medical license revoked
main thing she was saying general public
won't know this because why do you need
to know this it's not in the news but
like the main thing she was saying
anyway was like
30 years of my medical career i've never
seen any changes to how you
the um the process of a death
certificate straight away
before kovid came out gps were getting
holiday all doctors were getting told
from above you get me
don't get twisted because you're a
doctor you're a doctor get me you're top
done blah blah blah but you still have
to answer to someone bro
you know what i mean if that's the top
of the nhs who's obviously the nhs
kind of get they get all their gut their
their guidance from even prime ministers
from the who so they said yeah of course
they do but the who the world
health organization they're like all of
the countries they are
essentially i won't say telling them
they're advising them what to do you
know what i mean
and and this is where it's all coming
from so it's not as i'm saying it's not
coming from our government you know i
mean this is not a conspiracy like this
is truth in it
it's just i've decided to apply critical
thinking i call it critical thinking in
it
i've decided to apply that like and and
this is the get me she
knows agrees with you he knows man's
like one you get me
so you think like the government and
that are doing this
some sort of control yes no so what what
is the benefits of the government
lying about this virus exactly what are
they getting out of this
what's their plan i can't sit and say
this is their plan like
but if you look at how how we how we
live our lives anyway we
i wouldn't say we're fully oppressed but
there's there's certain
races i get to why i do that that are
oppressed definitely we know that let's
talk about
um black black people they're oppressed
you know if you look at what's going on
in um
china chinese government that are
oppressing uganda muslims like
millions of them bare of them are going
into camps why
you know what i mean so if we talk about
like my answer would be oppression but
then we've always kind of been oppressed
yeah
in like certain cultures yeah yeah yeah
but so elbows from up north right yeah
why are they putting stricter laws on
towns and places oh london gets treated
differently london's getting all this
freedom and everything have you ever
have you ever heard the quote
london isn't isn't a veronica of england
no i haven't
london the city of london is a different
city
it's not in london anyway it's not real
england is it it's nothing like anyone
cause i'm hearing like someone was
telling me pubs in
liverpool tell me if i'm wrong i'm
hearing if you walk into a pub in
liverpool they're asking you first
question
do you live in the same household if you
don't yeah yeah yeah yeah can you sit in
there
no seriously i think people outside of i
think people are in my opinion people
don't think it's that stupid people
outside of london
are more than they're looking but then
but then why but why is it like that but
then maybe not locked down
but then why why are they giving
different laws for
those places in london the first time it
happened was the night before eid in
manchester because everyone goes to
wilmslow road
when you see and it's like a big party
and they knew it was gonna happen so
they locked it off then
so again racist not just uh he liked
what goods just said racism
i don't even call it racism because
there's one thing like well it's
suppression like you said yeah yeah it's
impression but like back to like ricky's
question what i don't i don't know what
their
benefit in it but in a sense it's more
control in my opinion
it's more controlled it's full-on it's
full on control you know i mean even
like down to the app man we'll know like
to the app thing like i basically look
at china in it i look at and this is so
mad to be like i sound like trump
look at china you know i mean you know
like let's look at china
like what's this guy know about china
what i know about china bro in certain
cities in china it is full on a press
bro even like
we know him i'll make julio yeah i don't
even know this he told me this he went
china like i think it was
fat knows maybe three four years ago
when he went china him and his mate
went to buy uh because in certain cities
again in china mosque has been
normal for time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you can even look at it it gets mad how
we used to look at the chinese
the chinese government have full on
censorship on the internet they're kind
of facebook they're kind of honest
it's a whole different yeah yeah yeah so
if you think about like the information
they're allowed to seek
is limited yeah and it all comes for me
it all comes down to limiting what
people are allowed to do
like the control in it so um china you
got you got the train tickets somehow
when he got to the
um to put the tickets in him and his
mates mixed it up and
the tickets won't work because the
facial recognition system clocked and
their tickets didn't belong to the
person putting it in
you know what i'm saying yeah i'm mad
none of you man have downloaded this app
have you
no no no bun that bro wait it's just
that when oyster card came out it's just
it's just tracking and it's just
trekking up everything yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah but my my i think we'll feel like
we're
digressing a little bit for them to shut
down the country like they have
and to lose the money and to go into a
recession that we have
i don't see that as a benefit to them in
one bit i don't know how they could how
they could plan that how is that good
for them
100 that's what my dad says as well and
that's what even certain times i still
question i think like but really
but then if you take yourself out of
let's say like all we know of how
society works and the economy works
to reset it right how did you reset it
you got to crash it
you got a crash it and what what did we
hear all the time we heard the big reset
the great reason
you got bro see demanded do you think
they care about
what ruining us yeah well if they
haven't lost the people
they do not care about ruining your
lives bro they do not care because why
if they cared why please like you could
go through many things
but like people are living in [ __ ]
poverty why do they care they're taking
away what
before this all happened they took away
the kids man man pays for kids to go to
school you know everyone's there because
mums can't afford to go to school
because the government made those cuts
coming out of our [ __ ] budget when it
should come out of their treasury you
know what i'm saying
you know what i mean and it's like
that's how i know they don't care bro if
you look at even like all right covid
how many people died or
um the statistics of kovid heart disease
outweighs that massively
cancer weighs up massively so what
that's that you know what that point
there
that's when i started to think i was
like well what like me anyway this is my
opinion what am i living in bro
you know what i mean like what am i
living in if i let me strip everything
back let me take away chris goodson this
identity man
i own good money let me take away my
career all of that let me strip this
back for a second and just put some
critical thinking into it
because i've got my kids i think about
my kids think about their future
what's my living in bro when heart
disease so where's the panic for heart
disease it's the best [ __ ]
you're right so there's better [ __ ]
that's way above it and then this
coronavirus thing has come
and it shut the world down but then
right we've had all these other things
what are all this other things why have
you not tried to attack people
people are unhealthy well why are they
unhealthy you know what i mean if you
talk about the
the the reality i guess we live in you
know what i mean why are they unhealthy
we look at all the [ __ ] we sold
you know what i'm saying being sold to
us being advertised to us man all know
this because we work in advertising yeah
you know what i'm saying there's certain
there's certain gigs that come in
certain gigs that come in recently man
looks and i'm like this is
trash bro imagine sell some trash so i
mean there's no benefit for people
whatsoever
for what it's a consumerism for man to
make money you know what i mean so what
do you think about because
i got told by a nurse
and what she said was that if you have
kovid and you
i think we all know this if you survived
or whatever and then three weeks later
you walked in the street and got hit by
a bus
your death is still going down there's a
covered desk if you got hit by a boss
well yeah yeah that's what happened and
a nurse told me this so that's
true you're believe so when you don't
look at the numbers so they're basing
all their
the new rules the new lockdowns and
everything on numbers
in cases yeah cases cases the numbers
what do you do
yeah so even the numbers are using all
this membership well the numbers are
[ __ ] because even now they're saying
the numbers are going
up of course they're going up because
it's easy because you could get tested
now before you can get tested
now now the normal person you get tested
is more testing companies than in
schools
and stuff so listen to this of course so
my mom just had to go
on a last week right and you had to have
a test to get on the plane a 48
hour old test so she took a test on a
tuesday her flight was on friday
paid 170 pounds yeah private test
to get it within two days so then
there's some survival
they lost her test they lost their test
the laboratory the laboratory laboratory
no they're well corrected though the lab
the lab let's go to the lab
the lab is in northern ireland
so she had me bailing up northern london
to check if they got it and you know who
picked up her test to take it
the royal mail something as important as
that
yeah yeah hey why is the lab in we're
like what will we one of the top five
top ten countries in the world
yeah it's a joke all the way over there
it's
i'm still part of this country nobody
shouldn't be so far why is it
travelling overweight it shouldn't be
out of london really and then and then
why
why is the royal mail picking up
something as important as important as a
as a as i said it's a deadly disease why
is the world
picking up your test for a deadly
disease i don't know bro
and so she had to do another test and
she was on them she got that test
negative
obviously and that's fine but she's
still
what 300 340 pound down or what not
that's a flight somewhere do you know
what i mean and
and she doesn't she don't we don't know
who to chase up to get the money back
or not even though they lost it the
people that are doing the testing
so it's like the whole thing is just the
whole setup is a challenge and i'm
reading things that
one testing companies is owned by um the
prime minister's mate
no but that's like that's like you know
you know circo events like it's just
like you know circumvent
you transport prisoners the more
prisoners they are the more they make
well it's funny
so anything's privatized
imagine needing sick people imagine
needing prisoners to make money yeah so
yes that's a whole wider thing
but my question my question to you to
get a little deeper is what would you
say to people watching this
whose mum granny sister have died or
they've been sick themselves yeah and
we're all
i say we because i believe it's real
yeah but you're kind of flippantly
saying this coronavirus isn't real
what do you say i believe it's real but
i believe no way
what what would you say to them because
i feel like we can't just
dis disregard the numbers that we've
been told
but there is real stories out there yeah
100 of them i'll be
like it's hard to be like what would i
say to them i can't i'm not um the guys
be like
what i believe i mean yeah exactly what
i would say is essentially like are
these people have
pre pre-existing health conditions so
could it be something else because the
symptoms are the exact same symptoms
says influenza there's a lot of symptoms
that shared with like say
lung disease and stuff like that you
know um i would say
in my opinion anyway this is my opinion
like you're thinking you're going off
what six months of a new virus and
totally
oh this person's got this person's got
this person's got it you're going down
to a pcr test what people get diagnosed
with
this is what i've again what i say to
people is a pcr test look at kerry
mullin i think his name's kerry mullin
who's not funny enough he's dead he died
in november but he created the test
so he's the creator of the pcr test that
essentially is
that's the test you know um you've got a
nobel prize for it
so my man said this should not be used
for medical diagnostics
so this is this is again this is not
conspiracy this is facts go out and like
this is what i say to everyone in it if
like who if your
your family's had it or whatever um who
am i to deny someone to say they haven't
got something in it
that's what i'm saying i'm not i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna act like how they
act about it
man i say certain things people like i
won't get let in shops or i get
jobs taken away from me or certain stuff
like cool that's the name you know what
i mean i was like
but like quick to end my opponent and
that what i say to them but do your
research bro go and ask the doctors what
they really got
because i'll go on to saying about the
death certificate so i've got a friend
who works in a bank i can't say the bank
uk bank massive
massive works in the bank but i've seen
probably 36 maybe death certificates
with probable
covid 19 on it so it's not certified
that this is why they've died
it's called probably just goes back to
what i said about the doctor um
the the northern irish doctor gp who
said
never seen in my life 30 years of
medical work um
death certificates being changed she's
like she's like she said you have a
cough that could be put down that's
right yeah he's got coving you know what
i mean
like you said about the the motorcycle
thing and they've even they've even come
out with wishy
wishy-washy articles of like oh yeah if
you get tested it's whatever
um i think it's what zero to 28 days
whatever happens with
between that or something 14. yes again
like people could die of
my nan my nan had a stroke my nan
eventually died of ammonia that's what
she that's what old people catch in
hospital
you know anyone's there um again like
i hope everyone anyone who is is unwell
obviously like i hope they are hope they
recover i hope they have
great health man's not here to discredit
you or to try and make you feel worse
like man's just coming to have a convo
but that's what i say to you my mom
wishes you good health obviously do your
research
stay healthy make sure you eat your
fruit and veg so i mean keep the immune
system going
um if you smoke don't smoke you know
what i mean look look after yourself
question
question have you been looking after
yourself but you'll be at the same time
your biggest thing is this
scaremongering
there's a lot of fear monkeys are not
fear-mongering and you think like we're
being
i think any any anyone who says there's
not fear-mongering
is is i don't know they're in doubt like
to anyone
if you believe it or not everyone knows
there's bare female regulations
look at the news conferences they look
like war conferences bro i don't know
two little [ __ ] don't
you don't i don't think it's
fear-mongering i think you don't think
so i think it's
the government trying to pass the blame
on constantly and it's
it's slightly different i don't think
it's
i feel i i think they're just trying to
pass the the the blame on to the general
public and not how they handled the
entire situation
everyone was clueless clueless yeah yes
i don't think what i think as well they
would they wanted everyone people
forever people's attitudes will change
forever people
forever scared 100 people so anxious to
be in public places to go on the tube
to do this to do that kids are going to
be homeschooled now
i think i think that's what that's why
the government shook the country down i
don't think it's for any other reason i
think it's because every other country
was going to do it and they would have
been looked at as useless
they didn't want to chuck this [ __ ] up
i don't think they did that to try and
get control i don't think i personally
don't think that that's what it was
about i think that they
everyone would have just held them more
accountable if they didn't do that well
and they still are because
you know because what they keep saying
is that we wanted to look down too late
yeah yeah they still say that they still
say
i don't know i just i just think and
then i do think since then
people at the top have taken advantage
of this and made money out of it
so getting contracts from the government
which are [ __ ] all this track and
trace thing how much you've gone through
spending ridiculous money on ppc i feel
like it was
i feel like it would be i feel like it
wasn't the direct cause i think they had
to shut down then opportunities
so yeah it took me the opportunity to
make the there's there's stuff in there
there's way too many questions there's
way too many questions way more
questions than answers than this
i don't i don't think they they designed
it i think they just took a like yeah
took the opportunity
but i don't think they're designing i
think they got told what to do again
what you said
why they got pressured into it by the
who the who were telling countries to go
into lockdown look at italy it went from
china
but again like this is this is if you
look at wuhania wuhan
has the worst air pollution in in china
so wuhan went first started here so if
you're looking again yeah this is this
is this is quite conspiracy issue
but man will say in it because this is
entertainment at the end of the day you
know yeah yeah so man
if you're looking to start a fake virus
they're saying yeah
you need somewhere with you really truly
you need people with like
um the way they went for their lungs
they need people with bad lungs you know
absolutely
yes this is bad lungs yeah you're seeing
wuhan yeah it's the highest
pollution everyone
where was the second place italy right
yeah everyone's bailed in italy as well
yeah most polluted most polluted in
italy
like man's got chat and [ __ ] it's all
out there go go do your research you
know what i mean
um that's why it's kind of conspiracy
but it's kind of not but it's um
it's mad because obviously there's a guy
this is this is um there's a guy
obviously you heard of him david ike
there's bear guys i listen to it i read
um but yeah when he was saying that he
was like oh yeah
like i was just thinking i was that
brave imagine that that you know what i
mean like
it's mad isn't it like there's a city at
first fighting behind it it's also
a contagious virus center that's like
for experiments yeah yeah yeah so
[ __ ]
anyway so my question to you is goods
mask talk to me that's not a question is
it about
mars how do you feel
about the government and everyone's
saying
we gotta wear masks you know like
walking in a restaurant going into a
shop getting on the train going to
school
how do you feel how do you feel because
i know
that you all know you know i mean
especially this guy yeah
yeah that's true the viewers in it yeah
there's no study to show that most like
work again
i think i said earlier on that that
analogy man had of like um
the the mosquito and the defense blah
blah blah
right because the size of the particles
of the virus they say
yeah it is so small that it will travel
through but you've taken it to such a
level no no wait go on
right the same people who hate masks
like that
i won't say hey no no no but just don't
agree that they'll help viruses also say
that they'll reduce the amount of oxygen
in your blood and stuff like this not in
your blood you recycle carbon so it's
not over time if you wear it for say
longer than like a 20 minute period
you're starting to recycle your own
your carbon in it i don't know what you
said about that but what i'm saying is
if
if if it's open already how are you
doing that yeah if the holes in them are
so big
it's proven that's why doctors don't
wear them past the only time they will
wear them is in the procedure and then
they get binned you know i'm saying if
you look on most packets of a mask it
says not to wear it long in 15-20
minutes
look at it bro it's there i'm not
showing the [ __ ] you know what i mean
that's my opinion
secondly if moss do work the wife case's
case has gone up
since we've been wearing masks someone
please tell me that okay if marks do
work
why is why he did why why is boss man
respect to boss man giving me chili
sauce salad bringing me my turkish
yeah why is he wearing a mask i ain't
got where i'm at yeah it's dumb it's
dumb
you're right there's there's bad
dumbness about it but the case is going
up
what people don't talk about is touch
blood
it's true though in it when you're on
the tube you touch this opening the door
on on an escalator and then you scratch
your eye like people forget most
like really no one's no one's coughing
in your face unless you're on a busy
or on a busy tube in the mornings or in
the evenings
outside of that really no one should be
that close to you everything
you should be wearing i think so
actually but i don't want to but it's
bear dump no
but yeah if that makes sense no i don't
think so but i think to touch is
is almost as dangerous if not more
dangerous because
really has anyone breathed in your face
today
what have you all done with all high
fives
you know i know yeah but some people
right outside of a pub
how how can you wash your hands if
you're not in an office at home
or or in a pub that's why people carry
all the time my take on mars is that
it if it saves someone by myself
by one percent that love yeah
if it saves him or saves a granny or
saves myself yeah
one percent like that i totally
understand isn't mine i'll wear it
they've got people driving in their cars
on their ones
wherever yeah
team people in the gym i've been seeing
people in the gym on the treadmill
you've got one on the way in and then if
you're spotting someone you gotta have
one yeah
so i told them but exactly that's what
means you said you man violated my
contract so i'm not paying but a house
with my team and that's what they did
they can't
exactly that's what i mean but you've
taken it like so obviously me rick elbow
actually i don't know about elba but me
and rick like i said if we know that's
that one percent one percent to get on
the train to get something to do for you
uh if you go to a shop and they say to
you i'm not letting you in because
you're gonna go
yeah you'll turn away
each individual's perspective of oh your
life's going to become long now
it depends on how you live your life
that's why man started growing
vegetables like man serious bro you know
i mean that's got vegetables in my
garden right now i'm looking to get a
lot more so i can get more vegetables
exactly what you said man is hit the
nail on the head
it broke my life's long at certain times
bro whatever i can't go and get certain
stuff i'm with my kids
i've got to go and get them food bro i
need to get them food i need to cook for
them i make sure there's fresh food all
of that
but man's found my way you know what i'm
saying of doing it
the way i believe bro you know what i'm
there i haven't been told what to do
since school fan
and i'm a grown man i'm nearly 30. i've
got two kids in my opinion this is all
my opinion yeah i only got two kids
[Applause]
once in my opinion i've got to where
i've got to
again me personally i've got to where
i've got to by doing the
way i think doing what i want to do not
in a in a childish manner
no you're in a way i think i should have
been here
i could never be so stubborn yeah yeah
not wearing masks that i'd get an
allotment to grow
exactly what i'm saying is there's no
reason
in it i understand then again
if you know me in it people be like you
know what really when i think about it
i can see chris goodson doing that
because he's that he can be that
stubborn yeah
you know what i mean but when i'm saying
i'm not trying to be stubborn oh look at
me
look what i'm doing no one's saying that
you're really honest you know what i
mean like that's my little project you
know what i mean that man is doing like
because i'm
eventually man everything they chuck at
me like you said in your life gets
longer today i'll come back in it i'll i
will i'll find an alternative way
for me i won't put it on insta i won't
try both to buy it for me to make sure i
can feed my kids
and show them what i believe to be the
right way of living life
and what i'm saying is what if your
kid's school turn around and be like
i've already had chats with them right
but like you're taking them out you know
i'll take my kid out and i'm
homeschooled a minute
that's the god's honest truth you know
that's just showing how
you just said you've got to eat science
they're gonna be [ __ ] idiots
i know more now about science i've said
everything in school you know what
everyone's there
ever you know what i mean you know so
how how is this
cause you've been very very vocal yeah
very vulnerable yeah
and quite quite aggressive in it leslie
isn't it yeah i'm not i'm i think i'm
like that if i'm gonna if i'm gonna say
something
i'm gonna say it you've been having
tension
how much how much has this affected you
your work because me and you did
do the same job yeah yeah yeah yeah on
set they're very they're very stringent
yeah
in their new regulations and rules yes
how has this affected
your your bank do you i mean has this
affected your money not my bank no so
like
man saved enough money in it yeah to say
well new money i mean work
new money so
like straight honest answers yes really
yeah so like
so from before lockdown like um before
even before lockdown i was working at
copa 90 doing some work for them and
then as it's gone into lockdown still at
copa
then i was off i think for a week then i
was like bro i've been up until a month
ago i was working every day
yeah you know what i mean so i've been
lucky yeah you know what i mean and then
yeah
i'm a i'm clued up in it at the end of
the day manchester united i know what i
say
has implications hundred percent i know
that you know what i mean
so yeah i don't know what we do you know
brands
are watching our instances and stuff
like that anyway bro i'm telling you
when i was at
a lot i'm not like the last company i
was working for i'm working this i'm
saying but i've got work i'm working
this week
as well for last week yeah two days here
and there but like i said that's
something about the money
it's about how you live your life which
it took me a long time to realize
man just don't just go and spend waste
money no more you know what i mean like
i just got to be smart about it
um man saved enough money from like say
the last two years of being
self-employed to be
semi-comfortable you know what's that
yeah i'm not i'm not living month to
month you know what i mean
which way i have lived my whole life
which all i've known which my parents to
live
you know what i'm saying somebody's had
to grow out of that you know what i mean
but back to that
yeah it has but then again i don't know
if you might see this as a stubbornness
or what but i was outside talking to um
said cameraman and um and elbow just
there
and it's like i don't see myself working
in content much longer yeah
and it's you know what as well it's mad
because i i so it's so easy to cut you
but i don't
think i don't think even even though you
just said that which is new to me i
guess
uh that you don't see yourself i don't
think that that's
the reason why you you've still been
vocal by it i think that's just
just you that means yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
so i think there's two sides too i think
it's either
two type of humans you could you could
say some some people say oh this guy's
either stupid always best stubborn
yeah just bite your lip and crack on bro
you can make as much money as you can
more people are going to be like this
brother believes in what he believes in
and nothing else is shaking that it's so
it's so sturdy
work school whatever and he's just going
to crack on and
people applaud that so i mean yeah they
might yeah exactly there's two there's
two sides of it
exactly what you said in it like there's
certain don't get twisted a certain days
man sits there and i'm like yo like
do i need to do this but it all comes
back to
it hasn't been just this it's kind of
mad bro like when man started working
out
like properly hasn't really worked out
in my life properly i've got a pt and
all that
started working out eating right like
cooking cooking food essentially man was
every other day eating takeaways yeah
yeah living like
not looking after myself my my primary
in it you know what i mean because this
is all secondary
like that's primary in here fam you know
what i mean i've never looked after
myself i always smoke
started looking after that brother i
don't even know how but man started like
looking into spiritual stuff and i
started meditating bro you know i'm
saying
as this corona stops going on man
started meditating you know what i mean
yeah
and i started reading into essentially
like consciousness so so
like this is going to be mad yeah but
like so
we we 90 of us don't really we're not
really that conscious all the time you
know i mean we live in fort we live in
like the past or we live in the um um
the future we're trying to predict
things like he said like almost what
we're talking about but if you don't if
you don't work
you know what i'm saying that's that's
kind of it's kind of it's not a downfall
man does it as well you know what i mean
but man's trying to become more present
you know that one's there and trying to
be like
live in the now and this is only because
of me the way
the way i've kind of lived my whole
whole life i've lived in my head bro
very good point in that a huge music
exec who i used to work with years ago
told me about that and i got bare into
that years ago about is
i don't know if it's similar to what you
as but but it's about training your
subconscious
rather than your conscious in order to
make big decisions in your life
you know people say uh your your gut
feeling is that you're only
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's actually better
than your brain because you're 100
percent right so you're training
yourself to listen to that because
that's actually that's your
consciousness you know what i'm saying
i'm trying to talk to you into it yeah
the way i look at it is like when
like when you're born and no one no one
can deny this in it so then just
i don't know don't or do go and think
about it when you're born before they
give you that burst
or even way before that but your parents
give you that name and you're told
like you're a baby bro you don't know
you're black you don't know your wife
before you're told you're white
you're crying right you're crying yeah
that's consciousness blood you're
already there so wait
before the full man comes into that
you're this person yeah you're chris
goods and you're white
man's alright something's already dead
already on the shelf something's already
there fam
so that really and truly cool man crazy
that's not
us blood you know what i'm saying
because man was given that and this is
what it comes down to about
this whole thing like even the certain
people follow me like why are you not
talking about black lives matter as much
as you talk about this
i'm like bro really truly want to deep
it but man's talking about
everything man's talking about the human
race get it
human race yeah like we are all one fam
you know what i'm saying it's only
systems and economies and what we live
in that we
that we we come into this so that's what
i'm like [ __ ] black lives matter like in
terms of like the
the movement and all that but because
you man can all vouch for it from
look at okay look at me i'm not just
talking about me
not even defending me when i worked at
unila look at all the talent who i work
with look at all the
music i would use for whatever reason
for whatever bro man's an advocate for
black people
where you grew up exactly exactly you
know what i'm saying so like no one can
ever question that for me
but it's not for you to speak on it
anyway so i don't know why
like man will i'll speak on it and
defend any black person but when i say
it's deeper than that bro come back to
like
that's something man's been told we are
you know what i'm saying it's harder
it's hard to understand
it's hard to understand i just think
you know what i mean and i'm not saying
that with no so negative like
certain mindset like the way i'm looking
at you now i'm seeing like
you now have taken that line of your
morals over money
and everything bro i've had more money
like say in the last two years than i've
ever had in my life and it's not like
it's not a
major major yeah no no it's not but yeah
and that's why
the last couple months spiritually well
i've been looking to say like the facts
and i've been looking into yeah and now
you've been looking into like facts
stats on both sides i've been
you know what i'm saying man listens to
both sides because what
like certain days i'm like but no i'm
like would they really do that
you know what i mean i'm like come on
bro i'm like would they really do that
i've got to think about it after maybe
talking to my dad or something you know
what i mean
and then again it's maybe sometimes it's
too much fall in it that's why i said
like the last two weeks
maybe yeah two weeks i've just parked it
in it i know what i believe now isn't it
you know what i mean like yeah
can i can i ask the question how how
dangerous do you think it would be
if the whole country adopted your
mentality
i don't think it's dangerous at all you
know at all no no i don't
that's why i broke and this is i guess
it's a point i wanted to make because we
were talking about earlier on so like
when man started looking into this and
started like voicing my opinion
there was a there was a protest i found
that was going on in london yeah
and i mean i caught maybe it was maybe a
month ago now i think it was early
september
you've been reaching for five you've
been reaching yeah so man when i was
like yeah [ __ ] it i went on my own you
know i mean
same with blm i went on my own you know
i mean because at that point man was
kind of i was
i don't get assisted what the blm thing
and the racist thing
100 100 we know this though in it yeah
we know this but we know it's deep in
that we know it's systematic we know
it's been [ __ ] spread from time yeah
and even look at education like the
amount of
i think it's petitions that said they
wanted to teach actually the real
like um real history about i think it
was slavery or black consumers
[ __ ] too right they should as well
you know what i mean too right you
should know who you [ __ ] are you know
what i mean and what your country not
who you are but what
essentially britain your country is so
perfect and essentially it's done
throughout the world and in history they
say but um they ain't gonna do that they
throw that out
you know what i mean i don't know why
they do that why do they do you know
what's [ __ ] as well why do they do
that all right listen listen to our [ __ ]
this is
it you see germany and the nazis and the
world war yeah because they owned it
does anyone really now
associate them with the nazis just
english football fans
yeah exactly yeah yeah because they
owned it and they said yeah
we were shithouses yeah well britain we
would never own up to
what we did with uh taking over the
world and the whole commonwealth
we're not we're not gloating about it
but it was a different time the world
was let's just take over which is fine
to just say like this is our history we
like to teach in schools bro
i think this one thing i was talking
about someone the other day because we
were talking about is it turn up is it
touring the guy that done that broke the
um enigma code
did that sir alan i don't know is this
her alan turing yeah
but the enigma code right and obviously
he was gay
he was gay i didn't know he was gay
until i watched them films that come out
a couple years oh yes
but when you're in school they're
teaching you about oh yeah we we broke
the [ __ ] enigma code they sat the
other but they didn't go into the fact
that
he was gay and then they they he just
got pardoned a couple years ago
to me it's almost like a scripture it's
like yeah
it's like i think it's because it's like
children and they're just like right
what's
nice for them to hear it because that's
the wrong word they just show
the nicest parts they can they talk
about not even the nicest parts but they
talk i don't know you remember
you think i've had at school you know
what about slavery you watch roots in
primary school did they bring
them
yeah yeah exactly so so what bad things
did you hear about did you know about
the lions
so so like nothing wrong exactly so so
my thing is
so my thing is good your kids are right
what they're in more
are they even in infant school yet yeah
so logan's four he started
reception uh yeah reception so by the
time let's say
by the time they reach secondary school
they're going to be talking about this
in history i guess right
oh what this i highly doubt it no i
think it will so
the thing
they're going to have to talk about this
the same way we randomly know about
stars and [ __ ] and make
it secondary
you know i don't know the numbers but i
don't remember them did they do they
teach that in school
like do they remind people of it no i
remember i think this because this is
where would they
touch it science like where would you
teach it science
or finance finance economy
so i mean maybe i don't know maybe so
but would this be
yeah you could write a dissertation
and what i'm saying is really be
something that they'll curb how they
tell the people of course like they're
doing it now they're doing it they're
covering what they told the people
no it doesn't even say what's happened
now that is my
that is my question if the world changes
a complete mad amount and goes
completely different
on a mad tangent now because if this has
happened then it'll be a history point
where it's like this is watching
it it has to it has to be it might be
back to normal then you're gonna be like
oh
this was just a magic trick then that is
my christmas do you think do you do you
think so what do you think do you think
we're gonna go back to normal
that's what i was gonna say we're going
to be in this at least until next march
that's a year no one was ever thinking
when we say what you know
but yeah but when you say in this what
do you mean after yeah it would just be
like fine oh there's no masters no
there's no
like for you like for you man now like
do you so do you do you man think like
moss are going to go away do you know
i think they're here forever for some
reason i feel like they are i don't know
i think it will be optional and a lot of
people
it will be optional and a lot of people
will be optional i think it'll be
optional there was a point where
you couldn't you couldn't be like you
couldn't just get on a train
and have a [ __ ] mascot and definitely
think you're going to rob somebody i
think
if you're doing this yeah
because you're getting stopped yeah
spencer's here i went to get some food
walked in there and a lady goes you got
masters like nah
um and she was like can you just do that
please and i said you're serious she's
like
i might not have the sun there she's
like yeah can you just do that please
put your t-shirt over so i was like
cool so i literally walked away boom put
it down and i mean a
man walks around like it's just like
some people
it's maddening shops are getting
pressured in it yeah by councils or
you're going to get fines in it to
oppose this yeah but then you find like
people
not even like me people just don't they
don't see it as that serious like why we
ain't got a mask
but do you think like in the future your
glastonbury's your
full cinema we adapt into humans
now i think everything's going to change
you can't have a million people in one
state at one stage and [ __ ] like that
hundred thousand people you can't bro
i reckon it comes down to this
vaccination every time i went i've ever
been to a festival
or it might be just a track and trace
thing where you're open to it yeah but
come on what are you doing at the
festival
no that's what i mean i know you know
what i mean are you giving a lot of bad
stuff you're getting session
away from the festival it's still that
that sort of like actual illness after
not
you get hung over and like come down
here for two days and then you're still
ill for life
so yeah
what i'm saying is so are you saying all
these massive events
are done no what i'll say is that we
always
if you can prove that you've got a test
and you've got a negative test
actually very simple you can get around
it yeah yeah yeah but i think everything
is
where you come down to like you'll get
marks of being a citizen as they do in
china you know what i mean like if
you're if you're green you get certain
allowances indeed at a
potentially it could go that way that's
that's my opinion it could go because it
is
again it's not conspiracy this happens
in china you know what i'm saying yeah i
mean
i think they're even rolling out sweden
where sweden like we all know should
know
sweden didn't have a lockdown so you
know what i'm saying he's still on the
list you can still go
hey sweden i'm literally looking at the
stats there on the break
sweden they're killing it like they've
got like low well i'll talk about
emissions i don't talk about cases
because men could go
and take a test and say yeah that's a
case but that bro that's the case bro
they send you home
if it's a deadly virus bro they send you
home
how's that how's it should be people use
something how's it deadly brother how
are you getting in the position
this is a new home bro it's not deadly
hospital admissions are again are low
hospital missions right now for fluenza
more than kovid's blood remember the
video do you remember the video
of the brother in the in the excel thing
and he's like yeah bro
he scared everyone and he's like waste
of space have you heard anything since
waste of space they were like we're
prepared do you remember that video and
he was in there and he was like yeah
there's like a place with dead bodies
there's like there's hospitals here
no bro yeah since then
and and they've done the big opening
when they cut the ribbon and said yeah
and go open i don't think one person is
being broke like all right you know it
you know him i won't say his name he's a
free runner yeah my man went there
his name will block it out no no no i'll
tell you after um barry went then he's
supposed to spare times
empty empty empty i remember even
talking to a nurse
um and she at that point she was
defending it she was like oh no i think
they've closed it i think they're
closing it because they can't afford to
keep it running
i'm like just just just think about what
you just said
you know what i mean like that just
makes no sense do you feel like
the seriousness they're talking about
this there's exceptions for
things that make money so they're like
football they're trying to get people
back into school yeah yeah yeah yeah
trying to get 60 000 like do you oh
[Music]
as much as we do brother i really think
that they are
clueless of course so they're trying to
say okay numbers are going down
okay by october november we're going to
start to get football fans in
numbers go up they say no you can't cool
[ __ ] changes it and they have to adapt
the same way we do
if numbers go up or down you have to say
no football going back that's
not fair targeted the wrong thing still
now so
they've opened up universities and
schools and then yeah
and then and then instead of instead of
being like oh we [ __ ] up let me show
you something harry i'm going to send
you just to put an edit here and because
you've probably
you've definitely
schools and colleges 40
yeah everyone's there it goes back to
instagram thing how many times ago man i
rate sheep yeah no one's there because
sheep don't even police each other they
need the sheepdog see us man
that's my will please see each other bro
man don't need the sheep though
you're not wearing your mouth oh you're
not doing that that's more than six oh
i'm gonna call the police
what brother why is it come too fast why
are you policing each other
don't live your life i don't care what
you do you know what's there do you
sound hot do you do this yeah do you do
that
yes you can do whatever you want you can
be whoever you want
any race any sex do what you want that's
how i see that don't don't start getting
onto like
say example me or other people because
man's not wearing a mask you know
what i'm saying is even though i've been
saying now rule of six right
like my thing again money makers you
know that they're not letting
anyone in the football stadiums but like
there's 22 men on the pitch they're all
touching each other
it is different because they have
doctors and they're getting tested daily
or weekly
professional footballers don't be silly
brothers
so you know it comes down to the money
involved that's one so for that to be
able to happen the doctors the nobel
the so it comes they don't know
everything about them they're privileged
enough to have the
even if they've got these sniffles even
before current korean virus they're
getting dale getting tested
weekly their bodies are mot daily and
the thing about the football thing here
i reckon that was like a a mental
healthy we are a country who loved
football
when the football came back mentally i
could talk to myself in it yeah you were
guest
ghast bro i
and hundreds of thousands of boys and
girls and lads
who are doing the same thing so mentally
for the country i know that that helped
to [ __ ] money
do you agree with that interruption
you're looking at a good way but they
definitely wanted to make their money
yeah
i don't think are they making money
though well i guess they're still making
that the broadcast money tv money
money the bigger clubs are making
shitloads of money still the smaller
clubs
right really badly affected by that
they're even putting pressure on premier
league clubs
to try and help out here yeah not me
because but
which is mad but no silly little way
like you showed me that pretty little
thing that
that dress the dress with the moss oh
yeah
the show but at least at the same time
what do you like
[Music]
what do you expect companies and brands
to do brother if i owned a clothing
brand
i'm making a bad boy mask yeah
oh you made money from it i don't give a
[ __ ]
no
if it's morally right or wrong but it's
always going to happen when you live in
a capitalist society
man sees opportunity man's going to make
it last yeah like i said it was mad so
he showed me it'll come up on screen but
you had a picture or whatever of like
the
the chick was it was it a full outfit
it's like a dress that's all wrong one
or one oh it's all in one i've seen
chicks this one's about to get on it
i've seen something
one of them
[Music]
the bedroom tonight but i've seen girls
my point was that i've seen
i've seen it a few times out girls with
matching masks for that outfit so that
you got
like i think it's like a sparkly master
in a sparkly outfit
and it's just mad for me it's a magical
scene no that's kind of nice
because
oh and you're like oh [ __ ] that looks
quite bro everyone wears a mask
like everyone you lose your beauty you
lose your beauty in it
oh yeah you do you lose your beauty you
got all right you've got a bundle
okay yeah yeah so what you got right
here i think the opposite
i think this one's there might be some
someone might see some beauty in here
i'm not here to like [ __ ] if you're
ugly now thinks you're beautiful you
know what's there
well someone will find you no one's ugly
in this one
you're killing your beauty you're
killing your ability to speak you're
killing your ability to
like it's literally to what you're
saying you're back to your point to
breathe even though yeah oxygen can come
in but
don't come on like you're limiting it
reaction as well
i'm on a train i'm like smiling like a
kid
the virus particles are smaller than the
whole
particles must be yeah but you're
limiting it so like you are blocking it
you know what i'm saying but yeah but
we know that you know we know that
through the numbers we know the masters
are not blocking it because the numbers
are rising where everyone's wearing
masks
so if they're if they're working why are
the cases rising is
nothing happened and i just i was ill
for four days but shagged
got out of bed oh i'm all right again
now it's quarantined for the well
it's on quarantine anyway so nothing
happens i know it's about anything
i've got a mad mad theoretical one yeah
it's just like now everyone who gets a
bit ill they test them anyway and then
they're just like oh yeah of course they
get tested
let's just live in a fantasy world for a
second say if you could have a
one-on-one conversation with someone
high up
in in the british politics yeah and that
she said to you
yeah bro you're right the marks don't uh
actually work
medically but because uh mentally
it makes the public feel safe safely
and and the anxiety levels will have
been going through the roof
um mental health has been going through
the roof suicide has been going through
the roof we want to get people just back
to normal even through this horrible
thing in order to
it's because it's so important rather
than physically like mentally feel safe
what would you say to that well so
so if if they said right this is why we
put mars on we put we
we bring mars in mandatory to make
people feel safer
yeah i don't me personally i just can't
see how it makes
people feel safe it definitely does it
might make him feel safe because right
yeah i get it about the virus but then
you talk about suicide and stuff like
that like
the suicide is about their life bro and
they're oppressed and about they can't
go and
for example see their friends or they
might have lost their job yeah you know
what i mean and you're indoors like i
see i think if you wear a mask you can
that's that's
you can go see your friends if you could
wear moss you can go to a pub now yeah
you can go to a restaurant so it's like
so it's like so it's like you you can
have your livestream
my point is you're like but they haven't
said that though they have people
people can't people can't deal with
their life stop him
work girlfriend who lives across london
yeah
that this that people can't deal with it
so people with mental health has been
terrible people don't like being in
their house for a long time people don't
like being bored
people so my point is just living it in
a
theoretical world where we're agreeing
with medically
it doesn't it doesn't do anything but
mentally if we're like we can get
people back and not being anxious
because people are going to be scared to
go on a trip
people are going to be scared to do this
let's get people just like slowly they
work so so so much because even before
march when boris sent everyone back to
work i remember
i was on the train that day but i was
coming up into old street flooded fam
like normal the whole
and what i would time back to is being
like do mass work
see what you're saying there is
psychological so it's not it's but it's
not about health anymore exactly
everything
no no no no but i'm just saying listen
everything is suicide makes people feel
better means that they can come out and
see their friends that means they can
come and do this
it's not about health but that's about
psychology
it's not it's about psychology i'm
saying it's not about a virus
it's not about physical health it's not
about it it's just about saying but yeah
but
they're not coming up right you can wear
masks so you will feel better if they
did then i i couldn't deny what you say
you know no one said i couldn't argue
with it but they're not coming up being
like
they can't see that because they're
saying when most people know that that's
what i said
like theoretically if this if this is
just a psychological ploy
to make people feel like there's safety
please i think make them feel like
all right is that okay i i can't i'm not
here to say if anything so i'm not god
is it is it
all right i don't know i can give my
opinion
would yeah would you think morally that
that would be a good thing for the
government i think it's stupid
i think it's stupid because why won't
you come out and be and just be like
look
take the moss off you can go out be too
distant like sweden
you didn't have mars who didn't have
lockdown just use your common sense
keep your two me two meters from
everyone um so what like i think
that's my opinion makes people feel
anxious no thank you bro
thank you thank you bro i feel safer
thank you bro
thank you i feel anxious now i've only
started finishing i finished two sides
so yeah i think there's 100 in that but
i think
we adapt quicker and we'll get used to
it at the end of the day
i believe that 90 of people are only
wearing masks because they're being told
to and it means they can carry on with
their life and yeah them to them
there's two things there have zero zero
to do with your physical health which
this is all the viruses about so
i mean so my thing is i don't know if
this is dumb or this is just me being
stupid or trying to reach here
so sex right
we all wear condoms when we have sex
yeah of course
medically yeah they hate ourselves from
sexually transmitted this half flip no
no this is great
this diet is great we've been told as
well that we can get sexually
transmitted disease
through um through the mouth and stuff
yeah yeah
but then why so let's say all right so
if you're with
no it's just going but i mean so if you
always if you're with someone
don't say don't take the longest don't
take the long way around this yeah
it's more true so you you you're with
someone you don't know you'll get brain
off them whatever you want to wear a dom
yeah when you beat them you wear a
dumbbell your nose or you can still get
essentially chestnut disease through the
mouth but you
can't so no so my point is i get your
point
you get my pregnancy say it say it say
you're saying like so we we
kind of all know but again we don't
think about it really we just go
in we're just going certain times
without a dom like not saying just ask
this is like men in general
you know what i mean yeah even women to
certain things they're not being
protected
yeah and then all of a sudden man's bare
protective like i'm wearing masks but no
sure
man don't even dom up it's true and
because they're like
they don't even wash you know they're
taking the camera they don't even wash
bro they're taking the gamblers and
they're massively dirty
yeah you know what i mean like you're
probably getting more germs from that
mask
and then you would have it off you know
what i mean man they're not brushing
their teeth and putting on a mask
potentially in it we don't know right i
know blood
i don't know i want to make a point on
it because it's something that i didn't
say in it yeah it was up
for so for a while like mama's coming
out on instagram ranting in it and
you are going in you reckon
i don't know if i've lost friends i've
gained followers
this is a mapping about it's a mad thing
bro
like people are talking about it
and then like people i know but don't
know like i know this yeah yeah yeah
yeah
follow me
there might be some people that have
lost people because of corona
and you're out here it's not right yeah
yeah yeah yeah he might be people he
knows
oh he knows okay because i've been quite
lucky i don't
even have a third degree of separation
that has even caught it
but you might you know i mean well
michael is out here just spitting your
knowledge
yeah yeah yeah and like rick said is it
a bit insensitive
like have you have some people come up
to a bit like
my nan whatever yeah
i feel like maybe a couple times i've
been i've been aggressive in it yeah but
i think like in every sort of like
run man would do man's i always want to
let people know like yo bro
i do truly come from a place of love
like man says this with love because
i i care about people's health and i
don't see this as healthy
i don't see this as being healthy but
for whatever reasons for whatever
research man's done whatever we
spoke about you know what i mean so that
that's just how i see it
man i care about people's health if you
can't believe that then don't believe it
in it it's not a big deal but i
will still go smoke my zoo and carry on
my date i care about people's health if
that's
anyone's health you know what i'm saying
not smoking no smoke
so you gotta try to out so you don't do
anything
exactly this is what i'm saying i'm not
saying i'm the healthiest guy
you know i mean there's things i do that
are not great for my health smoking
what i mean you've got to be honest with
yourself you get me i'm just i can't be
that's why man's not an advocate or
man's not on this cult following a man's
like that's it
it's just my opinion what i believe in
and i'm not looking for no light
yeah ask first them yeah i mean so you
were going to make a point what point
were you going to make oh yeah so like
for a while like as i was as i was um
like
ranting on instagram posted stuff then i
thought about the protest
man i almost thought i was on my own in
it in terms of like the way i see it the
way i think
right because right for example mama put
like putting stuff
up i'm only getting negative replies
maybe one or two you're getting like
yeah positive
you know i mean replies um and then i
went to the protest in it yeah
and bro it's like honestly like man i
won't lie to you man i was like 30
of 35 bags bro they won't put it on the
news obviously so you won't see like how
many people there
and my songs are normal people bro man's
talking like i remember like the thing
that stood out to me the most was like
this oh he was probably looking like a
fed
somebody's next to me and i'm thinking
like this is definitely some feather
sign
and then he's in there i can't remember
what he said but we just started
chatting my man's like a 45
48 year old he's a dad lives in
manchester come down for manny on the
train all on his own
he's like in my house he's like he
basically feels better alone he's i
can't talk to another house
you know i mean he works i can't
remember that he told me the name i
wouldn't say it
high up in a sweet or sugar drink
company
got sacked you know what i'm saying got
told to cut because a cert he's like
in there he's like basically it's all
corrupt anyway he's like mate you should
see them out shocking sugar they're
putting in this
that don't surprise any of us really
you're in it when you like think about
it you know what i mean the amount of
sugar that's in products
yeah that our kids are eating and all of
that it's just the way the world is bro
but yeah and he was like yeah it's an
out on out [ __ ] disgrace and i'm
saying man was like he was he felt like
how i felt no no one was there like fell
i thought
people told my right phil rifle you know
i met this black guy in it yeah
it's mad i met this black guy i met this
um somali girl sharing with a somali
girl for time it's arabian girls with
this arabian girl for time she broke
you think i'm mad this girl's not not
mad
bro this girl this girl's talking to me
about different realms and like
different
all the dishes that people's eyes are so
weird but it's mad it's like
but i can talk to anyone most time in it
but it was nice it was a nice feeling
you know you know what like
whatever everyone like i said it's all
love man can think what they think i can
have your opinion
yeah i was like you know what like it
gave me more confidence they'd be like
bro just be you in it just be you do
what you think
just don't try upset anyone you know i
mean that day there i was like you know
what because that was
brother i swear down it was no violence
it was just all love it's like
naughty scouse is there i'm talking a
bag of naughty scouts
yeah and like you just better love you
know what i mean they're causing no
trouble
so you're like the people you've lost
like
i guess not talking to you or argued of
you or whatnot do you care or you just
like man i don't care
it's this um a lot i'm at my age i'm at
that age anyway i've got two kids
i ain't got time for but if if not
someone i want to talk to me
carefully it's their business it's
totally neutrally cool you know
everyone's there like
there's no animosity bro you know what i
mean like everyone everyone has their
own path
like got [ __ ] to do and everyone's there
like man's trying to not think too much
what i was saying
like things happen don't get twisted my
process is it and then boom
we move you know what i mean yeah time
to wrap it up can i write that word
well i think we all agree that no we
don't
i think we just all need to do what we
need to do to sort of protect each other
but let's just have our [ __ ] lives
back you know what i mean
it is what it is at the end of the day
but you go wash your hands wear a mask
if you have to but
i'm over it just let us do our thing
like and i've been i'm not
i've been quite active you might know me
you know i know i'm out all the time
i've been going to my
my bars i've been having parties in the
park i've been doing this
i'm still negative i'm feeling [ __ ]
after getting on it from three days
for three days like you for three four
days
even outside coming back from someone
going oh man i feel so poorly i'm gonna
go get a test just like
go matt come on
i think there is corona virus i think
yeah there is i think i think there is
but let us
are you going to let me do that i'm
sorry
i think there is there is virus i think
i think i think we've been lied to bear
i think there's more questions there's
than answers i think there's been some
stupid
decisions i think there is some i think
there is some sort of
uh oppression thing going on i think
there is a change that they want whether
it's like
a cashless society or something that
will come i do not want to wear a mask i
do not want to do all of this [ __ ]
but if i can crack on and live my life
and like i said if it help if i'm saving
a granny by 0.1
because i'm wearing a mask if one little
particle doesn't come out
i'll wear a mask and that's it elbow
yeah i'll wear a mask but uh put morris
johnson
take back control of your life in it
like you control your life in it
don't just take back control of your
life look after your health drink enough
water
and essentially you should be healthy
but yeah educate yourself take back
control of the information you want to
receive
you know that one's there like there's
so much censorship on insta on facebook
on youtube
there's like they they essentially
control what what they do again it's not
conspiracy this is this is facts
they control what you receive as
information and we can only
we can only have a perception of the
information we have perceived you know i
mean that creates
the perception man has so go and read
books as well blood
get kids off ipads [ __ ] say that pisses
me off
and uh that's about it man boom look
after yourself
stand up podcast um
you